ah le chant des baleines c'est
particulièrement relaxant
oui sauf que ce qu'entendent les baleines, c'est pas exactement ça...
il ya quand même toute une partie en
ultrasons et en infrasons...
Une équipe de chercheurs de Montpellier
nous apprend que cette sensibilité aux infra et aux ultrasons
est apparu très tard dans l'histoire évolutive des baleines.
Et c'est ce caillou qui nous le dit !
Ce caillou est un morceau fossilisé de l'oreille d'un protocète.
(une sorte d'ancêtre des baleines et des dauphins)
Bon...en fait, la chercheure m'a dit qu'il fallait mieux dire :
le cousin de l'ancêtre commun des baleines et des dauphins.
Il vivait il y à 45 millions d'années
...et il avait des petites pattes !
et oui !
ce qu'on sait, c'est qu'aujourd'hui ses descendants :
les baleines à dents
(comme les orques ou les dauphins)
utilisent les ultras sons, trop aiguës pour l'oreille humaine, pour se localiser.
Un peu comme les sonars de nos sous-marins.
A l'inverse les baleines à bosse utilisent les infrasons (dans les graves cette fois-ci)
pour communiquer sur de longues distances.
Revenons à notre protocète !
Il entendait quoi lui ?
En regardant le fossile comme ça on ne peut pas en déduire grand chose.
Les chercheurs l'ont scanné avec une
technique appelée micro tomographie à rayons X.
Cela leur a permis de voir d'infimes différences de densité entre l'os fossilisé et la pierre.
Et voilà comment on passe d'un caillou à la reconstitution 3D de l'oreille interne
d'un animal qui vivait il y a 45 millions d'années !
Et ce, sans abîmer le précieux fossile !
Les chercheurs ont ensuite montré qu'avec une telle cochlée
(c'est le nom de l'organe principal de l'audition)
notre protocète ne pouvait entendre ni ultrason ni infrason !
Comme nous !
Par contre, il pouvait entendre à la fois sur terre et dans l'eau,
ce qui correspond bien à un mode de vie amphibie.
La capacité à entendre les infrasons ou les ultrasons serait donc apparue plus tard,
une fois que les baleines sont devenues des animaux 100% aquatiques.
Cette découverte laisse donc entendre...
...que l'histoire évolutive des cétacés
serait bien plus complexe qu'on ne l'imaginait.
Voilà, donc le chant des baleines à l'époque,
ça devait ressembler à un peu autre chose...
Abonnez-vous !